Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning and supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of
discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton podcast.
So I thought we'd do an episode
sort of career advice in a way
episode for people who didn't
see it already.
I did one in the first season,
which was essentially more of an
academia versus industry
question.
I'll, if you're, if you're on
YouTube, I'll, I'll try and put
a, a link to it here.
But if you're listening, you can
just search for it.
I think it was in the first
season.
I can't remember which episode
now and but you know, I had
pretty positive response that
people find it useful, you know,
at different career levels just
to give some of my personal
opinion and things that I've
observed and learnt along the
way.
But I thought in this episode
maybe we would just focus purely
on the industry as a non
academic job, so not university
or sort of classic research
positions.
Might do that one again, let me
know if that would be
interesting.
But I thought just give some
personal observations that and
things that I've learnt along
the way that maybe I wish I'd,
you know, known in the past.
So I'm going to try and cover
maybe four or five things that I
think would be useful to know
for someone who is looking to
get a job in engineering to
understand about potentially
different roles and options and
the the different markets.
So sort of companies, job roles,
career progression.
And then maybe a bit of a deep
dive on actually the tech
sector, something that obviously
I work in and some people have
asked me, you know, to, to
understand a little bit more
about what sort of roles are,
are available and, and what it's
what it's like.
Again, caveat, this is just my
opinion.
I'm living in the UK.
I'm going to have a sort of UK
slash US bias to, to all of
this.
So if you're listening from a
different country, apologies if
some of this isn't as relevant
to you, but I, I think most of
what I'm talking about
hopefully, hopefully is.
So we'll, we'll, we'll assume
that we're basically that you
have some form of degree or
you're about to, to, to, to
finish a degree.
I appreciate that there are
routes without having a
university degree, but maybe
that's for for for another
episode.
So I'm going to assume that you
have some sort of engineering
degree.
Well, it could be computer
science, it could be a more pure
engineering, it could be sort of
more mathematical physics.
But let's say you're sort of
interested in something I would
call related to engineering,
Although to be honest,
engineering is a very broad field
though, and you could include
software and mechanical and
aerospace.
But anyway, let's not get too
much down a rabbit hole straight
away.
And so I'd say the first thing
that you should consider is what
sort of company do you want to
work for?
And the way I would tend to
split this up is you have large
enterprise companies like a
Rolls-Royce, an Airbus, a
Siemens, an Ansys, companies
that have tens of thousands maybe
of, of employees.
And then you have start-ups,
which probably are the complete
other end where you may only
have 10 people, but often in a
very fast moving, innovative
sort of exciting way.
I would say there's then what
some people would call mid-
market sort of smaller
enterprise where you may be
joining a company that has, you
know, a hundred 200 people.
So quite a different sort of
company like that.
I'm trying to think of examples
like, I guess even a Formula One
team would be sort of considered
like that.
I mean, maximum 800 people.
I wouldn't call that an
enterprise.
Could be, and I'll explain later
why.
And then you have what I would
sort of call SMEs, sort of
small and medium businesses.
So these are sort of the catch.
Anything in between I, I, I
suppose where you're going to
have something that is more than
probably 10 people, but less
than than sort of 500 people.
And what I've observed is that
they all have the sort of pros
and cons.
If you're going into a large
enterprise company, let's say
like one of those big sort of
engineering giants in, in, in
the UK or the US or Europe, they
often have graduate schemes.
They often have schemes that
help you to progress within the
company and it's very common for
someone to join one of those
sort of companies and be able to
move around a lot just within
that single company.
So if you join, let's say, doing
aerodynamics or, or, or, or CFD
or like a fluids person, usually
they have the ability that if
you wanted to move more into,
let's say project management or,
or into some other area, there
may be options to do it because
ultimately they want typically
to stay in that company.
And so they're happy for you to
move around.
So in some ways the advantage of
that is you have a lot of
ability to move sideways and,
and potentially upwards because
it's such a large company and
they typically have very mature
schemes on training and
development.
So particularly if you're a sort
of early career, you'll have a
lot of help to, to progress a
lot of continuous professional
development and just, you know,
lots of support because
ultimately these companies want
to keep you, they spent a lot of
money, you know, employing you
through the interview process
and they're quite well set up
for that.
So that's the sort of advantage
of that.
They, but maybe the disadvantage
is that they can often be such a
large company that they can be a
little bit more sort of
bureaucracy.
And what I mean by that is
there's a lot of sort of
processes and, and tickets to
file because they've had to
scale out, you know, maybe they
have 100,000 employees.
So that can sometimes mean that
it's harder to know face to face
people because you may just be
speaking through a, a ticketing
system to speak to somebody at,
you know, within HR or, or if
you want to do something IT, you
can't just go to someone's desk,
you may have to file something.
So they, it's sort of a
different vibe, I guess.
But particularly at an early
stage, they can be quite useful
because, again, they're, they
want to to help you.
Now let's go to the complete
other one, which is let's say a
start up.
And again, I'm probably thinking
a little bit now, maybe we're
starting off, if you're sort of
more early career, the
enterprise one, as it said,
graduate schemes sort of safe.
They, you know, will help to
nurture you.
They're looking more for your
long term growth.
Let's contrast that with the
startup where you're essentially
joining a company that has to
work as quickly as possible to
deliver something because of the
way that they're funded, often
through venture capital money
where they've got one to five years to
to deliver something.
And so that is the complete
opposite side where the
expectation is, you know, you're
working night and day to deliver
something, which actually can be
quite exciting because you may
only have 10 people working.
You're all maybe in one, you
know, location or getting on to
it.
There is no bureaucracy per se.
If you need to go and get a
laptop, you just buy one.
If you need to do something, you
just do it.
It's complete opposite side.
And often they do look for sort
of hungry, excited graduates who
have just come out.
Let's say a PhD or maybe even
just a normal bachelor's or
master's degree, but you're not
going to get that sort of, you
know, continual professional
development that that sense of,
you know, slowly helping you to
do it, courses, training, you
know, you may have three months
to ramp up.
That's, that's, that's not the
way it's going to be.
So you're going to be on the
other end.
But the positive thing is if the
startup does well, you may have
been given shares, you could
financially do quite well out of
it and you have a buzz of
having, you know, delivered
something.
And in for some ways it can be a
way to very quickly gain
knowledge and reputation and can
help you to then move on to
other career paths because
you've had to, you know, so
quickly do something and the
startup is very exposed.
So sometimes, particularly I see
in the US going to join a startup
can actually be quite a strong
move for, for, for let's say an
early career person because it
gives them a, a sort of very
rapid head start.
And then I'd say, you know, the
sort of mid-market, the
companies that are sort of
in the middle.
I, I guess, you know, you're not
joining such a massive
enterprise company, but you're
joining something that you know,
will help you out, but maybe is
the best of both worlds.
You could sort of say that where
it's small enough that you might
have a strong community of
people.
You would, you would know, you
might have a, you know, a small
team, but there's enough people
within the organization and they
still want to sort of look after
you.
And there is, you know, career
progression either way.
And I suppose the SMB
business.
It it's sort of again, a little
bit closer to a start up that
often the, the funding model and
the career means that, you know,
they can't afford to be having
lots and lots of staff.
But one thing I didn't mention
is in terms of responsibility,
sometimes, and I think people
who work in Formula One would
find this, that there's always a
difference between ownership and
responsibility.
And sometimes when you're a,
let's say, you know, early
graduate, you're quite happy to
be given a very small piece of
something to work on and that's
yours.
But the other time, sometimes
you think I'd like to be working
all of it.
So as an example, you know, if
you're working in some very
large engineering company, you
might be responsible just for a
very, very small part of, let's
say, that aircraft design or
that car design, or that that
that industrial a piece of
equipment or whatever, whatever
it is.
Or in a software company, you
could be a software development
engineer just working on a very
small part of an overall
product.
But if you're in a smaller
company, you may actually be
responsible for, let's say,
designing the whole car, or you
may be responsible for writing
the entire application.
Now, probably by definition,
it's not going to be as
complicated because if one
person can do it versus needing
500 people, it's obviously a
different product.
But there's a difference between
sort of the ownership side of
it.
And that can often be something
and, and one reason that people
switch between sort of large
companies and small companies
because they feel they want to
have, you know, more ownership
or more, more scope to take over a
whole thing rather than just a
narrow fix.
So the classic example would be
in Formula One, a lot of people
that when they start, you know,
they're working just on a front
wing flap or maybe less so now
with the new rules, but
something very specific.
Whereas if you join, let's say,
a smaller engineering
consultancy company that's been
asked to develop an aero kit for
a whole car, you may be asked,
right, can you do the
aerodynamics for the car?
So it's a very different sort of
job.
Pros and cons on, on, on both
sides.
But then there's also an
interesting one, and this is
maybe where I see and probably
not as well known, but this
barrier between what some people
would call sort of traditional
engineering companies.
And that's some of the names
I've mentioned then like, you
know, your Rolls-Royce and your
Airbus and all the others.
And then what I would sort of
call the sort of more slightly
newer in a way, but commercial
or tech companies that actually
are increasingly doing more of
the engineering that the
traditional engineering
companies would do.
And what do I mean by that Is
there are consulting companies,
you know, like your Capgemini,
PwC, I'm probably going to
forget the names of these
companies, but all these sort of
large consulting companies that
actually do.
And, and I guess you could call
companies like Arup as well in
that they have specialist
teams and knowledge that help
perhaps some of these big
engineering companies to do some
of this work and they either are
essentially outsourced to that
company or they provide expert
sort of guidance into that
company.
And we could probably go into a
bit of a deep dive into this and
this whole idea that large
companies are quite slow to
innovate versus sort of smaller
or, or companies that are
focused on on that.
So there's actually a lot of
jobs for people to move into the
more consulting space.
And this is sometimes a little
bit of a controversial topic,
particularly the stereotype is
that some people when they
finish their engineering degree
will will not go into quote-unquote, a traditional engineering
company and will instead go to
one of these consulting
companies because there is a
perception of, you know, greater
money and a bit more of a sort
of commercial sort of
environment.
And, and to some extent that is
probably true.
Certainly in the UK it is, maybe
it's less so in other countries,
but there is this sense of these
consulting companies that quite
often, let's say they're based
in London, again, sorry, bit of
UK-centric view here.
And they can be a bit more
exciting because you may be paid
a bit more.
You're living in the city,
you're sort of working in a more
commercial environment where the
sort of stereotype of going into
the engineering company might
be, you know, you're in a
factory in the middle of
nowhere, which is sort of true.
But there are, you know, lots of
pros of, of working in those
engineering companies,
particularly if you really,
really love sort of engineering.
Now those companies are
realizing that and they're
obviously trying to change.
So the engineering companies,
the traditional engineering
companies are trying to, you
know, attract younger talent and
they're trying to show that they're
more innovative.
And I think that is certainly
becoming the, the, the case.
But I say it because from a
career point of view, if you're
looking, let's say on a job site
or, or or for places, if you're
into, let's say mechanical
engineering or automotive or
aerospace, there are there are
other options than just the big
traditional engineering
companies or even some of those.
And now we can get into what I
would call this hierarchy maybe.
And hierarchy doesn't mean good
to bad.
It's just in terms of the way
that they do it, the there are
many, many opportunities and
companies that supply to the big
companies.
So, you know,
Airbus may or Boeing may sort of
appear to be the aircraft
manufacturer, but in fact there
are hundreds or thousands of
companies that develop sub
components for them.
And and actually the large
companies outsource quite a lot to
it.
So it's very dependent on the
company.
But it's not the case that to
work on aircraft design, you
have to work maybe at a Boeing
or Bombardier or or Embraer or
or Airbus or whatever.
But there are sort of Tier 2,
Tier 3, et cetera, companies that
will build the landing gear or
the components or, or or again
do consulting advice to those.
So there's, there's far more of
those companies and sometimes,
and this depends on the sector,
it can be a stepping stone a
little bit if if you wanted to
get into the big company, but
for whatever reason there wasn't
a job available, then there are
options to obviously go to these
sort of smaller companies,
sometimes smaller to gain that
experience that you may then
want to have the experience to
go up.
And, and that's certainly true
sort of from a motorsport
perspective, the classic example
being people want to work in
Formula One.
There's only a certain number of
jobs in Formula One, so either
you just keep applying, but what
do you do in the meantime?
Well, actually then there are
lots of companies that are sort
of side auxiliary to to Formula
One, have a lower Formula One
series or companies that provide
things to the Formula One teams.
And this is probably where the
software side comes into it.
So again, I suppose I'm, you
know, maybe most people
listening to this I assume are
probably more engineering type
people, but maybe some of you
have also done a little bit of
what I've done, which is
appreciate that nowadays
engineering is very much a
software driven industry.
It's very much a sort of digital
industry.
And that is of course why there
are so many software companies,
software companies doing a whole
range of things that
increasingly have much closer
links to engineering.
And so for example, they have
the very large companies, which
I would still call them now an
enterprise like Siemens or Ansys
or Cadence or Dassault or or the
others which I'm probably
forgetting to mention.
These are extremely large
companies developing a whole
range of software that has, you
know, is explicitly designed to
some extent for engineering.
And so engineers are very
attractive both from a software
engineering point of view, so
developing the software, but
also we'll we'll come into this
in a minute in terms of job
roles, they want people with an
engineering background to be
able to either sell the product,
develop the product, research a
product.
So, and that is a very, I would
say, growing industry to the
point it's probably growing
faster than the traditional
engineering.
And it's also true that many,
you know, if you were to go back
40 years ago, those engineering
companies would have probably
developed their own software.
So if you go back and look at
the, you know, old school
Lockheed Martin or.
Or, or Boeing or BAE Systems or
whatever that was before it was
BAE Systems or, or certainly in
Germany and France and, and, and
probably in Asia as well.
And all around the world, 40
years ago, you basically had to
write your own code because
there wasn't first of all, you
know, computing and software was
far, far different and you had
to do it really yourself.
If you Fast forward to now,
there's a whole multi billion or
trillion dollar industry for
software to the point that
increasingly companies are
making a decision not to develop
their own software, but instead
to buy the software.
And increasingly also, and you
know, people know that I, I used
to work at a cloud computing
company.
It's, it's the same, it's the
same for that, that increasingly
now even in terms of buying your
own hardware or data centres,
you're looking to sort of
outsource it to another company,
which means some of those jobs
are being shifted to those other
companies.
So I would say the biggest thing
is the idea that engineering is
transitioning from the
traditional companies to sort of
the more digital or software
companies.
Now, that's also why many of
these traditional engineering
companies are trying to redefine
themselves as software companies
because they realize that that
really they need to become more
of a, a sort of software company
than just a hardware company,
particularly because of the way
the the the world is working.
And I've made a note down here
that I'm going to definitely
talk about AI because that is a
certainly a big one when it
comes to the job market.
But OK, so that's the companies
and I'm I'm purposely not
mentioning lots of specific
names because it's just so
country dependent and and
industry dependent within, you
know, the engineering sector.
But hopefully that's given you
at least what I would say is the
sense of the different companies
that that you could potentially
join or work for.
But what about job roles?
And, and again, some of these
people will know and be obvious.
There's some stuff that I don't
think I knew actually before.
So I'm hoping maybe some of this
might help.
So you do obviously have your
sort of traditional, quote-
unquote, engineering roles.
But what really is an
engineering role?
It's actually, it's quite, it's
quite different.
I would, I would sort of split
it that you have engineering
roles, specialist engineering
roles.
And what do I mean by that?
I mean domain-specific.
So in quite a lot of companies
you'll have a fluids group, a
structures group, a sort of
battery group, you know, sort of
more maybe the, the chemistry
side of it, sort of a noise
group, maybe looking at water
and, and, and soiling.
They'll be a manufacturing
group, they'll be composites
group, there'll be a sort of
physical testing group.
They'll be and they would hire
specialists in to them and
that's where you would typically
find doing a PhD would be useful
because they might want a fluid
specialist in in that group.
Now that is obviously dependent
on sort of the company and a
very large enterprise company
may have hundreds of people in a
dedicated fluid sort of group.
And you know, Oh well, like a
Formula One team in aerodynamics
division where you maybe have
hundreds of people just in
aerodynamics.
And that this is sort of linking
to my first point about
companies.
And if you are in let's say one
of those, you have sort of
career progression within that,
you know, oh, I could be a
junior aerodynamicist or senior
aerodynamicist, principal
aerodynamicist, et cetera.
But if you then go into a, a
smaller company, perhaps maybe
there's only one aerodynamicist.
So that aerodynamicist in some
ways needs to be potentially
more rounded and qualified and
given much more responsibility
because there's only one of
them.
So it there's a potential career
move from, let's say one of
these big companies where you
were one of 100 to just being
one because you may find that
exciting because you're owning
all of it.
So this is where there's always
a bit of movement between.
So I think there's sort of
specialist engineers and then
some people find that, well, you
need engineering managers
because somebody needs to manage
it.
And that actually is in itself
its own sort of job role and
skill.
Managing people, lots of people
is a full time job and is not
just a a sort of thing you do on
the side, at least for good
companies.
There's also a lot of sort of
project management jobs and this
is where some people find that
they actually really enjoy
organizing things and doing
things, but don't want to be
deep diving in one particular
sort of sub domain of fluids or
structures.
They just they feel like they're
an engineer.
And some people like either
become therefore more than
engineering manager.
There are in some large
companies that what they call
some chief engineers or
assistant engineers, but these
are people and there's a
borderline between I guess
project management and
engineering management.
But certainly I see that in in
some of the large sort of Rolls-
Royce-type companies where these
are the, these are the people
who are supposed to look at the
bigger picture.
How do you deliver that product?
How do you actually get that
thing out and you need to manage
or organize or direct, you know,
some fluids analysis here, some
structural analysis here, some
some manufacturing analysis
here, some maybe market analysis
here and you're coordinating all
of it.
And that actually is its own
typical job family.
They often the big companies are
sometimes the ones to get that
because they will train you up
in how to do it and sort of
move you between projects.
Certainly that's the case that
some of these large like the
Rolls-Royce, Airbus and
Boeing, well, they'll sometimes
almost have like schemes to
identify people like that.
Then I think it's important to
note that some people actually
like to go in to more of a sort
of cross in the middle, which I
would sort of call maybe
technical marketing where you
it's a marketing role, but it's
you've come from a technical
background to do that
marketing role.
And that's very common actually
in software companies.
So if you look in all the tech
companies, there are hundreds or
probably thousands of jobs or
what they call like product
marketing or technical marketing
and they're looking to hire
people with a technical
background.
It is not a pure marketing job.
You need to understand the
technical side.
And often it's people even with
PhDs or things.
And that can actually be quite
exciting for some people because
they may like sort of a
different side of, of, of work,
not just pure engineering.
And they may enjoy the sort of
marketing and sales.
And so that is actually
something that is worth thinking
about.
You can still stay technical,
but go into these more technical
marketing roles.
And like I said, in the software
world, that is increasingly
becoming quite a big one.
The other one, and I'm saying
this because I feel like some
people leave engineering because
they think, well, I'm either
just an engineer that has oil on
my hands or I need to get out
and do something else.
And sort of what I'm saying is
you can be an engineer but do
many other things.
And so a good example of that is
sales.
So some people may like the
idea, they may be driven more by
a sort of commercial mindset.
And some of those may be for,
you know, I just need to leave
engineering and go and work for
a sort of financial institution
or go and work just just outside
or not even do engineering.
But actually in many, many
companies, and again, a lot
software companies, certainly
true, they need people to sell
that software, but you need
people who are technically
minded to do it as well because
often you're talking about
complex stuff.
If you're trying to sell a piece
of software that can manage all
the manufacturing components or
some sort of, you know, fluid
dynamic software, you, you sort
of need to know the area.
So there's a whole load of
positions and jobs in sales.
And some of that is what they
call business development.
So it's more the strategy of how
you would do it.
I think what they call go-to-
market, or GTM phrase I'd never
heard before, but it's it's very
common once you're sort of in
the in the software or tech
market.
And then you also have pure
sales, which often they're sort
of quota driven.
So it's, you know, I need to
sell this this much a month.
And some people really love that
because it's sort of exciting
because you're, you know,
you're, you're trying to get to
target and there are things like
account managers.
And you have this again at
consulting companies or software
companies where you're sort of
managing a customer or a set of
customers.
Now, one of the big job families
obviously is software
development engineers.
And so they often call them SDEs.
And that is something that has
sort of blown up and something I
definitely was not aware of when
I did my sort of traditional
engineering background.
And what do I mean by that is
again, because of the software
need and they do have them.
They do of course have these in
these engineering companies, but
definitely, definitely in the
big tech companies.
There are thousands, tens of
thousands of SDEs software
development engineers who are
there to develop code.
Now, some come from a computer
science background, but many
also come from an engineering
background because you need very
strong programming skills.
But also it's useful if you have
some sort of mathematical or
engineering background.
And engineering tends to be a
good thing for problem solving.
And there is a huge market for
this, whether you're talking in
the the Googles, the Facebooks,
the Amazons, the NVIDIAs, all
those sort of tech companies and
other ones like, you know,
Netflix or, or or whoever else
to write code.
And there is A and I can talk
about this maybe in the in the
next section about the sort of
tech sector.
But this is really interesting
for or career option for sort of
engineering graduates.
And even I know people who have
in some ways retrained to go into
this.
So even if you have a job,
you may find it quite
interesting career path to go
down that route.
You may have to retrain in terms
of, you know, developing your
coding skills or software
skills.
But it's a very interesting
market that I think with the
rise of AI is becoming one of
the sort of dominant job type of
positions to have.
OK, so now maybe let's turn to
something I mentioned before,
which is the the tech sector and
how I think this is actually
increasingly becoming an area
very relevant to to engineers
and is only going to grow for
for two reasons really.
One is that there is a move to
digital engineering
certification by analysis and
that is true across the whole of
the engineering sector.
Whereas aerospace, automotive,
defence, manufacturing,
industrial, really any of those
industries are increasingly
using software to define, to
develop, to test their their
products.
You've all heard of things like
digital twins.
And, of course, this is
important: AI. Whether you
are a big believer in AI or a
bit of a sceptic, is becoming a
huge thing for all engineering
companies.
And that is a great opportunity
for for jobs.
There are many opportunities,
whether you're in the large
enterprise, I spoke about the
the small ones, the start-ups,
some will develop in house, some
will buy in.
So regardless of what they do,
there are many opportunities for
software jobs, which is
typically developed by tech
companies.
Of course, tech companies do
more than just develop software.
They also sometimes develop
hardware.
And so there is a blurred line
sometimes between that.
But, and again, some of you
listening will, will know this
very well.
And so apologies maybe to some
of you, but there may be some of
you are not so familiar with
this.
And so I'll, I'll say it anyway
and, and hopefully it's useful.
So what do I mean by the sort of
tech companies?
Again, I was not aware of this.
I will put my, my hand up.
I was not fully aware of this
probably, you know, 10 years ago
or, or even 7 years ago, I
wasn't fully aware of this whole
sector actually.
So, and, and that's probably
because it's traditionally being
a more US-centric industry.
And you know, being in the UK
myself, it maybe has only more
recently become a bit more
known.
And still, though, I don't think it
is that well known.
And I think that's true for,
for, for Europe and, and the
rest of the world.
So there are companies like
Amazon, like Facebook or Meta,
like NVIDIA, like Google, like
Microsoft, Oracle, trying to
think of other companies, you
know, those are the sort of big
ones, I guess now, of course,
OpenAI, etcetera.
But if we take the, the, the,
the big companies, what do they
do?
And, and by the way, there is a,
there is an acronym FAANG, which
I, I should have researched this
actually, maybe let's, let's do
some live Googling.
So it was Facebook, Apple,
Amazon, Netflix and Alphabet.
That was the traditional one.
Of course, now Meta, etcetera,
but that's just sort of an
acronym.
And then I think they call it
the is it Magnificent Seven?
I think I've heard that phrase
used.
But anyway, the, the point is
there are these sort of big tech
companies, but there's many,
many others and the sort of
start-ups increasingly that sort
of blur the line between it.
But what do they do?
Well, of course, if you look at
something like Meta, you know,
obviously they develop Facebook,
Instagram, WhatsApp, but they
have a lot of research teams and
they have products that they
they make as well.
And so physical products
sometimes that's certainly true
with, with Amazon and and
Google, who obviously have
devices.
So they have to, you know, make
devices, but they develop
software.
And you know, I used to work at
a cloud computing company, AWS,
and of course they have a huge
base of employees, you know,
hundreds of thousands of people
who develop software and you can
use it through sort of a cloud
interface.
And that's the same with Google,
the Microsoft and others.
So the tech sector is massive.
And let's focus why it's
interesting for engineering.
Well, a lot of and, and by the
way, before I do that, I should
say that is I would say that's
that's called the tech sector.
But I think it's probably worth
also linking that particularly
because we're talking about
engineering now with the
software market as well.
Because I think there is a bit
of a blurred line in the sense
of the Siemens, I think I
suppose you'd call it Siemens
Digital Industries, because
Siemens is obviously a very big
company.
Ansys, the Cadence, the
Dassault, you know, Autodesk
Synopsys, I'm probably
forgetting some of the other
companies now Hexagon that
develop software.
And these are very large
organisations, you know,
multibillion dollar companies
that that sort of develop this
software.
And so I would sort of tie them
in actually in the sense of, of
what they're doing, particularly
in terms of, of, of job roles.
So if you look at, let's say,
the tech sector, what sort of
job roles are there and what
could you be doing there?
Well, as I said, there are a
very large number of SDEs,
software development engineers,
people who are expected to, you
know, write code for a whole
range of different things.
And in some ways they typically
start off being generalists.
So a fungible sort of asset that
is just great at coding and
programming.
And so those are quite often
entry level positions that you
come in.
And at the beginning you may be
literally just working on any
piece of, you know, databases,
web applications, high
performance computing, machine
learning, you know, just really
anything.
And you may be just given a
small sort of task to do.
But in terms of career
progression, you know, you will
find that you'd become then much
more potentially specific to a
certain area and you would take
more responsibility where you
may end up either managing a
team of sort of software
development engineers, which is
often referred to as SDM (software development manager), or
you may stay what actually is a
sort of individual contributor.
And I should, I should explain
this.
And I realise I'm probably
rambling on a little bit in this
podcast episode.
So apologies about that.
I suppose I'm trying to make it
as if we were just having a
conversation in a in a pub, just
without the alcohol.
Typically in the tech sector, I
would argue one of the benefits
is that there are typically 2
paths, the management path and
the IC path.
Individual contributor and I
actually quite like that because
I think some people are
different.
I personally, I've never been a
manager and I don't particularly
have a great desire to be a
manager.
And sometimes in other companies
that can actually be a bit of a
ceiling to your career if you
don't want to, you know, manage
people, that might be it.
You could never progress because
the only way to progress is to
be a manager and a director and
a senior director.
And you know, as you go up where
actually in a lot of tech
companies, what's great is they
have a track pretty much all the
way to the top for individual
contributors.
And to go back to the discussion
I was just having about SDEs,
that's where there are this
notion of, you know, a principal
engineer or distinguished
engineer or senior principal
engineer or a fellow or whatever
the naming convention is in that
particular company.
And these are individual
contributors.
That can actually, I said be
very senior, but have no
management.
And that is something actually,
I think quite important to know
because some people believe that
the only way to progress is
essentially to become a manager,
which for some people they want
to do and they're good at doing,
but it's important to know that
you don't have to to do that.
So the, the SDE route is a very
interesting root if you are
particularly strong on the code
in the programming side.
Now I typically find that people
are are one or the other.
They're either very good at
programming and enjoy it, but
like, you know, foreign
languages, I guess, or they
really don't like it or they're
not very good at it.
And so the SDE route is
definitely more you like
programming, you're good at
programming.
But there is also an interesting
side that then has a parallel to
sort of project management in
terms of engineering.
That actually a key role is
software development managers
who have to, you know, organize
sprints and put things in in
dashboards to track progression
of, you know, which bit of code
has been developed here and how
does it meet this target?
And then it has to go through a
security review and AppSec and
a legal review, and then it has
to be checked by somebody else.
And this is whole sort of
management that happens in these
big tech companies.
So you do find that actually
people move over from sort of
traditional engineering into
this software sometimes as
software development managers.
So if you, let's say, are
someone who works at a
traditional engineering company
and you've been leading a group
of engineers to develop
something, you may actually find
there is a career option in a
tech company leading a team of
software development engineers,
particularly if it's related to
something in the engineering
space, which we'll get on to a
minute is, is quite often
increasingly happening.
And of course, vice versa.
You know, if you're sort of an SDM
in a tech company, you may find
there could be interesting roles
in an engineering company
because of the of, of the
overlap.
So that's that's what I would
call the engineering teams.
And this is an important
distinction actually that maybe
it's not so well known, at least
in my experience, all these tech
companies and I think it's true
also with the software companies
typically have two or three
broad vertical areas, which is
the engineering or product side
of the business.
I mean, this is true for pretty
much all the tech companies
where your responsibility is to
develop the products and
engineer the code.
So there's a lot of engineers or
you are in quote-unquote, the
sales bit of the organization
where essentially your job is to
sell the stuff that the
engineers make.
It's a very, you know, crude
distinction because of course
there is a lot of overlap and
there's a lot of information
exchange between the two.
And then sometimes under sales
is is marketing, but sometimes
it's a separate sort of
vertical.
And then quite often these
companies sometimes have a sort
of third or fourth leg, which is
their consulting or professional
services, which is essentially
when you have a product, you try
and sell it, but the customer
says I need you to help me to
implement it or maybe even
improve it.
And those are very large tech
companies quite often have a, a
special arm that is you quite
often would pay the company to
have people come into your
company to help you to do it.
Sometimes hands-on-keyboard
help.
So that that is actually, and I
think it's important to know
this because sometimes when you
look at job roles online, it's
not immediately obvious what
side of the business it's on.
And that can have an influence
in terms of what, what job you
would, you know, be doing.
So that's the engineering.
Now another role is product
management.
That is something that is very
common in the software and tech
sectors.
And your job is to manage the
direction and the definition of
the product.
Now that product could be a
piece of CFD software.
If it's a very big piece of CFD
software, it could be a
subcomponent of that piece of CFD
software.
So you are the product manager
for the meshing team or the
meshing bit of the product or
you are the product manager for
a particular cloud computing
service.
So you're the product manager
for Amazon S3 or for Google, you
know, blah, blah, blah, whatever
the name of the service is that
you don't have to come from an
engineering background.
And quite often, actually,
people come more from doing
an MBA, let's say.
But quite often, depending on
the company, while they do value
having a technical or
engineering background.
And then your job is to, as I
said, come up with the product
definition.
And it's slightly different than
the engineering and it does
depend on the company, but
normally the product manager is
the one who will think about the
needs of the end user.
The customer will sort of work
with the sales team to get that,
you know, definition of what the
product is or to help liaise,
you know, with them to define
what the product should be and
then work with the engineering
team to actually deliver it.
And of course, this is a team
effort.
So typically that project manager
will be, you know, very much
managing and tracking progress.
You know, this needs to happen,
this needs to happen, this needs
to happen at this timeline
timeline.
They need to be technical enough
to push back and to understand,
you know, if a customer says I
need this feature X or, you
know, to even understand what it
is and to be able to understand
the language of the engineering
team, you know, to understand
what what needs to be done and,
and sort of understand
timelines, etcetera.
They're often they're
responsible commercially for the
revenue of it.
So thinking, you know what,
what, how much should we charge
for it?
How much money are we making on
this thing?
You know, clearly the software,
there's either a license or or
some sort of fee for it.
And so that is a whole job
family of its own.
And you know, I would estimate
there are tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of, you
know, product management jobs
and very transferable between
companies.
Many people move between
companies because it is a skill
to sort of manage a product and
that again, very relevant for
engineers to, to, to do because
quite often they want a quite
technical product manager.
In fact, sometimes that's even
part of the title, you know,
it's sort of technical project
management.
So that's something if you look
for as sort of job adverts,
you'd see it as like PM-T or PM.
And that's like I said, if you
enjoy also managing and
particularly like some people
come from like an MBA background
or want to do an MBA, that's
quite often for them.
And the career progression of
that is often then, you know,
you manage a team of product
managers, you become a director,
you become a VP or something like
that.
That's something that I don't
think is as well known, but it's
definitely a career route for,
for for some people.
As I said, those would be
typically the main sort of
engineering functions.
You would then find, let's go
more into the sales part of the
business.
You would find a job family
that's quite commonly referred
to as a solution architect,
quite a sort of tech sector type
job title, but you know, very,
very common and something that I
find not all engineers know
about.
And so a solution architect,
depends which company you work
for, of course, is typically
somebody who works to architect.
It's going to be silly to say
this because I'm essentially just
saying the job title in reverse,
but architect the solution.
What does that really mean is
let's say you have customer A, who
wants to use a software product?
B. Well, first of all, maybe
there's not just one software
product, maybe there's many
software products and the
customer doesn't really know
which one they should use.
And then maybe they all need to
connect together.
And this is certainly true for
sort of cloud services and, and
the solution architect is
someone who understands how to
implement that solution, to
guide them which solution they
should pick, how to maybe link
it into their environment.
So I can certainly speak from
let's say CFD or high
performance computing background
solution architect would be
somebody who deeply understands
HPC and CFD and would be able to
say right, customer A, I think that
first of all, let me explain
what this product is.
So you have to be quite
technical and I think you should
do it in this way.
You know, you should use this
service and I think if you
connect it with this service,
you'll be able to then do this.
And you know, this is how we
could do your existing systems
and, and we'll work with you to
sort of architect a diagram, you
know, of how you would link all
this stuff together.
Maybe then there would be
somebody who would help to maybe
benchmark it, particularly from
a software point of view, be
like, OK, this is how it would
perform and they would work to,
you know, get that customer to
to then buy it.
And that's why sometimes it's
called pre-sales, although
sometimes that can be a bit of a
stigma and some people don't
like to be called it pre-sales.
But traditionally it's sort of
is that way that it's, it's
quite often engagement before
they buy that piece of software.
And some companies explicitly
call it pre-sales and they even
call it a pre-sales engineer.
I think that's a bit more true
in the software market, let's
say Ansys, Siemens,
etcetera.
But in the tech sector, quite
often it's called a sort of
solution architect.
And there are different types.
And this is where we could go
into so many rabbit holes of
specialist solution architect,
the more generalist solution
architect.
But it's important because you
will sometimes see these
jobs advertised, and increasingly
they are looking for engineers
and a lot of engineers just
don't know what the job is.
So that's why I mention it.
Usually the solution architect
is working also with some sort
of business development person
who is there again, in a sales
function to hopefully try and
sell that product.
But more than just sell, be an
advisor to, to the customer to
say, look, I, you know, working
closely with that solution
architect who is perhaps a
little bit more technical, but
the business development is
often still a technical role.
And many of the people I know
who do business development have
come from very technical
background.
They have a degree, even a
PhD, they've worked as an
engineer, but they just enjoy
the more commercial side, sort
of quasi sales.
So typically they work together
and again, many opportunities,
often a more pure sales role is
something like an account
manager.
And that is where there's a lot
of crossover to completely non
engineering roles.
You know, working at any sort of
company where you're managing an
account you're selling.
I mean that is just such a broad
role.
So those are sort of what I
would call the sales type of
positions.
Now I did mention that quite a
lot of companies have these more
consulting or professional
services side of the business
and these are usually very
technical people because their
job is to go in and practically
help a customer.
“Hands on keyboard” is usually the
phrase.
So whilst the solution architect
may give the advice, they're not
usually allowed to actually
touch a customer's account or,
or, or work on the thing for
legal reasons and, and
financially sort of wouldn't
really work out.
So often there is a, a branch
where they need technical people
go in and actually help a
customer to use that piece of
software, whether it's a sort of
web-based thing, let's say cloud
or whether it's a engineering
piece of software like CFD or
fluids.
And they will go in and help
that customer to use and
implement.
And sometimes they don't charge
for it.
Quite often it is a business
model to charge for it and there
are lots of jobs needing very
technical engineering people to
do that.
And that's again another job
option.
And this is that link to I
mentioned all those consulting
companies and sometimes they're
also called system integrators.
And those are companies that
will go in and actually help a
very large organization
typically to implement some big
change or big use of software.
And so sometimes rather than
using, let's say, a tech company's
consulting engineers,
they will go and use one of
these big sort of consulting
companies, whether it's, you
know, Accenture or it could be
Arup or it could be Boston
Consulting, I guess technically
and all these sort of companies
that operate in that sphere to
go and practically implement and
go in.
Often they also do sort of
strategy work, but quite often
it is hands-on-keyboard help.
And again, that is another
route.
They often have dedicated
engineering divisions like an
aerospace division, defence
division, etcetera.
Now the final piece is maybe
support.
So in software companies there
is often not just a pre-sales
but essentially a post-sales,
which is also referred to as
typically a support.
And those are also typically
very engineering focused and
they need to help customers who
have bought the software and
need help.
Some people transition between
pre-sales, post-sales and sort
of development role within the
engineering side of the
business.
And again, there are many jobs,
let's say Siemens or an Ansys or
Cadence, you know, hundreds of
jobs for people with engineering
degrees and backgrounds to
support customers.
And it's sometimes called
Technical Support to go and help
them to use and, and, and
develop the software.
And what's the further layer to
this is that there's often teams
specifically to cover, let's say
EMEA to cover America to be a
worldwide role.
So there are just so many
opportunities and increasingly
they're criss-crossing with the
traditional engineering
companies.
Sometimes the traditional
engineering companies are sort
of losing staff to go to those
or it could be that the
traditional engineers are
creating their own little teams
to sort of mirror a little bit
what happens.
But I think particularly the
tech sector ones is stuff that a
lot of people don't know about
and I think increasingly that's
going to be the case.
OK, final thing, I know I've
definitely been rambling on a
lot.
So if you have specific
questions, maybe put it in the
comments if you're watching on
YouTube is the AI side of the
piece.
There are, and in some ways this
is a bit of an overlap with what
I'm talking about, but it's it's
really to re confirm the point
because AI is becoming so
important for for the end
engineering companies, but also
for the software companies to
develop AI enhanced or focused
products.
There's a whole new set of jobs
specifically looking at AI.
And for me personally, I think
one of the biggest interesting
areas is either that just means
there's just more need for the
software development engineers
to program that sort of stuff.
But I would point out, and it is
a little bit more in this
industry at the moment, but it's
going to grow, is there's a lot
of need for people with
engineering, physics, maths for
AI and that's sometimes called
AI for science.
And if you've listened to this
podcast before, you'll see I've
had quite a few guests talk
about this AI for science.
But there are more than 10
startups and ISVs now who are
focused on using AI for
engineering and sciences.
And so they are looking for
graduates and early and mid and
late stage career people with
that background.
I would highly advise people
that that is a great area to
look to.
First of all, it is, oh, you
know, just an emerging area that
is very exciting and it is
something that not many people
have the skills on.
So it's quite a valuable
resource.
And so if you're, if you have
those skills, you know, that's
good for your career.
But it's really
bringing again this, I guess, arc
that I'm talking about of
software and traditional
engineering together.
Engineering companies are
developing their own AI teams,
software companies are
developing their own AI
products.
So it's a great area to be in
and really confirms this sort of
arc of there is more than just
traditional engineering, but
more so in terms of roles and
and jobs.
And I think you'll find that
hopefully understanding this
ecosystem of jobs and companies
will help you to make a more
rounded decision of not only
where you want to go, but just
in general what's happening in
the world.
Now, as I said, this is just a
personal opinion.
I'm probably missing out whole
sweeps of companies and, and
jobs and sectors and, and, and
probably I, you know, I'll try
and maybe do a few more.
I didn't really touch much more
on sort of career progression.
I didn't really talk about
salaries on purpose because it's
such a difficult topic to get
into with different countries.
And yeah, but I, I wanted to
just put this out because
sometimes I've had these sort of
conversations with people who
ask a little bit for career
advice and, and again, just
thinking what, what, what would
I wish that I'd known before?
So I'm happy to deep dive in
particular topic areas like a
particular tech sector, type of
job or, or, or type of position.
But yeah, maybe let me know if
this is on, if you're watching
on YouTube, maybe you could put
some comments if you found this
useful or if there's other stuff
that you would like.
But yeah, hope you enjoyed this
and we have a few more
interesting episodes coming this
this season on some what I think
are quite exciting topics.
But in the meantime, hope you
enjoy this episode and don't
forget to like and subscribe on
YouTube or follow this if you're
on Spotify, Apple, and if you
can give a rating that helps.
On the topic of tech companies,
there's a lot of algorithms that
work and unfortunately nobody
gets to see stuff unless there
is some user interaction.
So if you just listen to this
alone, that's great.
But unfortunately it makes it
difficult for other people to
find it where if you literally
just press the like button, it
sort of obviously changes its
position in the rankings and and
helps obviously me, but it helps
to get greater exposure, which
of course you don't have to do
it, but if you did, I'd much
appreciate it.
OK, I'll stop rambling now.
Thanks very much.